so the next one i wanted to talk to you
guys about is
um using negative calls to action in the
place of positive ones
this one is pretty tricksy but it works
super well and it doesn't mean
having a negative message like i don't
like you
it means just taking the verb and
turning it into the negative form of
itself
so remember to follow these rules versus
don't forget to follow these rules
what's great about don't forget is it it
shames people
it's this terrible thing that kind of
keys into the little child and all of us
to go
did i do that right and it makes you
makes you check yourself
pretty quickly and it's something that i
use all the time
with my team and and even customers as
well but it's a good way you can test it
to see how it works with yours i mean
it's pretty easy to a b test don't
versus
you know the positive version of it but
you'll notice that there's a lot of
tricks that we're going to go over here
that are on the psychological
testing side and that's one of them